Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to
how about Jonathan from Palm Coast,
Florida. What is Palm Coast, Florida?
Is that the Gulf side or Atlantic?
Jonathan from Florida,
Speaker 4: hello, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yeah, where is Palm Coast?
Speaker 4: Palm is between Jacksonville,
Orlando. I live in that area between.
Speaker 1: Oh, is it is it even on the water?
Because Orlando's like in the middle, isn't it?
Speaker 4: Most likely it's
like near Jacksonville.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's Atlantic side, right?
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: Good, good. All
right, well, what's going on?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I want to ask you a
question about the vaccine, if it's OK.
Sure. Well, I took this to show that the vaccine
already I took the Pfizer one. But I want to
ask you a question. I'm not fully vaccinated
because I heard that the FDA is approving the
third shot of the vaccine. If I may, I'm not fully
vaccinated yet. I get confused what they may about
FDA approved for third shot of the vaccine.
Speaker 1: That's a great question. OK,
so here's the deal right now. What the FDA has
approved is a two dose regimen, meaning that
10 to 14 days after your second dose, you're
considered fully vaccinated. Separately from that,
there is now a recommendation for people to get a
third dose eight months after their second dose.
So when did you get your second dose?
Speaker 4: At the 16th of August.
Speaker 1: Good. So you're considered fully
vaccinated until April of 2022. At that point,
you would be at eight months. And as of right now,
the recommendation would be you get a third dose
then. So there's nothing else you have to do
right now. You are fully vaccinated right now.
Speaker 4: OK. Makes sense, yeah, right.
Good. Thank you for your question, David.
Speaker 1: All right, no problem. No, thank
you. You asked the question. I'm giving the
answers here, Jonathan, but I appreciate the
opportunity to to answer anyway. Very good.